he also talks about how key foreign
policy issues will be impacted by his
possible successors hosted by the Hudson
Institute this is an hour and a half
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
I also welcome people watching c-span my
name is John O'Sullivan I'm a senior
fellow here at the Hudson Institute and
director of the Center for European
studies here also it's a great pleasure
to welcome you here to a discussion of
British politics have provoked by a book
by our first speaker Jeffrey Croft yo
blur which you may remember is a remark
that was addressed by the presidents the
United States to the British prime
minister as a g8 meeting earlier this
year now this remark may not have rung
around the United States but it caused
an enormous amount of I suppose anger
and resentment in England where it was
interpreted I think not necessarily
accurately as somehow condescending to
to mr. Blair but of course the reason
why it produced such an impact was
because there was already a great deal
of concern in England about two things
one is the situation in Iraq and
building on that the whether or not the
special relationship between the United
States and Great Britain was working to
Britain's interests and that was also
particularly associated with the Prime
Minister Tony Blair because he was seen
as having a relationship with Washington
in which and if this is the majority
view I think in England in which he was
in adopting two subservient to Rome
I think that's an interpretation that
wouldn't be accepted by everyone on this
side of the Atlantic or perhaps on the
other including perhaps some of our
speakers today well I'm going to invite
the first speaker jeff wheatcraft the
author of yo Blair and the author also
of a min fascinating book on the decline
of the British Conservative Party called
the strange death of Tory England to
begin the today's proceedings after mr.
wee Croft who is a distinguished
independent journalist and is the author
of sand historian and the author of such
books as the ran Lords I'm going to
invite him to address us on this
question then I'll invite Christopher
Hitchens and Tim Montgomery to respond
before I'll just briefly introduce them
now Christopher Hitchens as they say
needs no introduction he's well known to
Americans and indeed to Brits
the author of a number of books of
essays of of literary essays of
political essays and as someone who in
recent years has moved to some degree
across the political spectrum exactly
from where to where he went perhaps
explained today but he has taken the
strong defense of the Iraq war at a time
when many other people were moving in
the opposite direction Tim Montgomery is
a former aide senior aide to the former
head of the Conservative Party Ian
Duncan Smith and he's also and perhaps
this will turn out to be a more
significant role the founder and editor
of what is the major political blog on
the right in Britain w-w-w conservative
home comm so both of them approach these
questions from positions of both
commitment and independence and I look
forward therefore to the debate that
should follow could I begin by asking
Jeffrey Croft to address us and good day
ladies and gentlemen very good to be
here and to see you the title of my book
John has just explained I had been
thinking for some time past of writing a
short of vigorous polemic about mr.
blarin in particular his foreign policy
and it might have had various titles it
was what not inspired by but there are
echoes of a famous book published in
1940 by Michael foot and two others
called guilty men which was an attack on
the Chamberlain government before the
war and a guilty man might have done as
my title if it hadn't been for the
wonderful title which President Bush
presented me with absent Petersburg last
summer and although I have been told
that the phrase is not quite as
condescending as some of us in England
who thought it was the full transcript
of their conversation which we
subsequently read was a hair-raising in
the way that it showed Tony Blair really
bowing and scraping to President Bush
saying I I can just go out to the Middle
East and talk and I will do exactly your
bidding it did seem to come
firm the worst suspicions of most people
and it was a mystery magic moment last
summer in anglo-american relations as
well as an International Affairs because
the the crisis then exploded in Israel
and Lebanon and the Israeli bombardment
of Lebanon followed which was if you
want a contrast statistically between
the two countries House representatives
passed a resolution of unconditional
support for Israel by 410 votes to eight
at a time when almost to the day an
opinion poll showed that only 22 percent
of British people thought that the
Israeli response was proportional or
justified I would add I'll just say for
one for once here that although my book
is thoroughly polemical in tone what I'm
saying here today is with I hope a
degree of a historical detachment and
I'm not speaking simply as a polemicist
as it were therefore whether the
Israelis were right or wrong in the
response the objective fact as well was
that most British people did not support
it nor did most members of mr. Blair's
parliamentary Labour Party or indeed
most members of his cabinet but he
himself did and this has been his policy
throughout I think it can be shown that
his support for President Bush in the
Iraq war stemmed they no doubt mr. Blair
thought that Saddam was a dangerous
tyrant as who didn't but I think it can
be shown that it's stemmed from his
commitment to supporting the American
and his administration of the day in
which ever decision it took the the most
lethal criticism of Blair over Iraq was
made by Robin Cook who had been in mr.
Blair's first foreign secretary and was
then kicked sideways or downwards and he
resigned he was then an important member
of the government to resign over the
Iraq war in March 2003 and in his
resignation speech in the House of
Commons he said that the invasion of
Iraq would not be taking place if Al
Gore were in the White House now that I
think first of all is obviously true
400 as a latter-day critic of the war
discovered an eloquence and passion that
are quite eluded him when he was running
for president and what that means is
that although the Bush administration
could still say yes and thank heaven
it means among other things by the way
that if you want to ask the question who
took the ultimate decision to invade
Iraq you could say the Supreme Court but
while the Bush White House could say yes
thank Heaven we had a president decisive
enough and brave enough to invade Iran
Blair can't very well say that he's in
the absurd position of saying my policy
is to support the American
administration of the day I
wholeheartedly supported the decision of
President George Bush to invade Iraq
just as I would have wholly supported
the decision of President Al Gore not to
invade Iraq he himself is a great
believer in the special relationship and
that is my theme here the the I believe
again if one looks hard through the eyes
of history this very phrase is dubious
to the point of almost absurdity it was
perhaps a special relationship special
chiefly in the only one side knew it
existed and relationships don't come
more special than that
the English loyalty the British loyalty
to the United States has never been
reciprocated and again I emphasize that
there is nothing wrong with that on the
American side necessarily when the
accusation has made sometimes of
anti-americanism by critics of Blair's
relationship in particular with
President Bush my answer to that is the
United States is a sovereign country
that's the point of the fourth of July
it has its own interests and objectives
which it is entitled to pursue or as
interests as it perceives them at any
rate and which it does pursue often with
a disregard for the interests of its
supposed friends let alone its declared
enemies and this has been exceptionally
clear during the period of mr. Blair's
prime ministership and and above all in
the last six years and
the harder one looks at it the more it
seems to me that the so-called special
relationship has met its nemesis in this
the events of these few years to justify
it at all you requires to begin with a
rewriting of history or miss reading of
history
Sir Christopher Mayer who was the
British ambassador in Washington and
then raised a rather gossipy book about
his time here in Washington said that
when he was ambassador he forbad any
members of the Embassy's staff ever to
use the expression special relationship
he also said something else he said that
based on his experience as British
ambassador in Washington he came to
realize that the White House took
seriously the views of the governments
of exactly three countries Israel
Ireland and Saudi Arabia and there is
one country missing from that list of
what happens to him a British citizen
and he also observed what perhaps I
observed that you very about the special
relationship there was a most comical
exception to that last Norton when
Senator John McCain was in England he
came to speak at the conservative
conference and he then gave a long
interview to the spectator which is very
much an organ nowadays it wasn't when I
worked for 30 years ago of Anglo
neoconservatism under the anglo-american
alliance and I suppose Senator McCain
was being polite and seen for his supper
because he did say how much he believed
in the special relationship and he said
that I think the special relationship
will last throughout the 21st century
after all it has already endured for 200
years at which I said hello 200 years
back takes us to the early years of the
19th century or let us say to 1812 whoa
what was special about the relationship
between the two countries that year was
that they were at war I imagine that
Senator McCain has visited the White
House and he really want to know why
it's that color I mean some of us take
modest patriotic pride
remembering that the presidential
mansion had to be repainted after our
brave lads had burned it and I dare say
that Senator McCain knows the words of
the star-spangled banner' as well and
you should remember that it was a
British Rockets red glare and the two
countries were just as often on very
hostile terms throughout the 19th
century as they were on friendly terms
they did have become allies objectively
and more than perhaps just objectively
in the two world wars all that remember
that the United States only entered the
first world war
belatedly and only took in a part in
series fighting in 1918 and likewise the
United States after an inter war period
when the countries were not allies at
war and the United States Army was still
making plans hypothetically to invade
Canada the two countries became allies
after Hitler declared war on the United
States rather than the other way around
Beatriz it's an example of mr. Blair's
waywardness with history to say the
least that he could say he after the
September 11 attacks he expressed the
wholehearted support of the British
government of people for America and
quite right too but he went on to say to
a grieving New York that and my father's
generation lived through the Blitz and
there was only one country which stood
shoulder to shoulder with us at that
time and that was America well I'm sorry
the Blitz was the bombing of London and
other British cities in the autumn and
winter of 1942 41 when many other
countries were in fact were fighting on
our side and the United States was
neutral and it shows up the absurdity of
this this version of history in which
the two countries have always been
intimate friends and the Unites States
ofle began life in rebellion against
Great Britain and has been said by some
historians that even in 1914 sorry just
to go back a moment more Americans would
have wanted to join the war at that time
on the German side than the British side
we were allies to be sure in NATO for 40
years well in NATO has lasted longer
than 40 years for reasons that escaped
some of us because it was an immensely
brilliantly successful defensive
alliance which achieved its objective
with total success when
was Western Europe protected but in the
end the Soviet Union imploded and I have
sometimes wonder why NATO wasn't wound
up at that point but and this is the
thing which defenders of the so-called
special relationship and over the
present Alliance seem to forget during
the period from 1949 when NATO was
founded until 1989 when Russia began to
collapse the two countries were bound in
this intimate mutual defense pact for
the defense of and if you read by the
way the the the the the founding texts
of NATO you may wonder why how he can
possibly justify NATO troops being in
Afghanistan said today because it says
the North Atlantic area anyway during
that period the two countries were
intimate allies in NATO but they were
very far from supporting each other's
every endeavor outside the NATO area in
1956 the Americans conspicuously did not
support the British and the French and
the Suez Enterprise and I would say they
were right and that Eisenhower's
criticisms of Eden and his reproach
history and Sir Anthony Eden read with
not just great cogency but terrifying
topicality today when he said that if
you invade an Arab country you will
arouse animosity not only in the Arab
world but throughout the whole of Asia
or in Africa that will endure for
generations ten years later the British
did not support the American war in
Vietnam that has said Harold Wilson the
Prime Minister expressed sympathy with
the Americans but he did not commit
troops and do remember that was exactly
what the Americans wanted that was what
President Johnson wanted very much very
comfortably with Iraq because if you
remember mr. Rumsfeld said as the
invasion was beginning the British
troops worked was his usual lack of tact
he said that British troop troops
weren't really needed not for military
reasons as it turns out he was wrong
about that because very many more troops
were needed then he had recognized at
that point
but they were there for political
reasons to show that there was the
famous Coalition of the Willing well in
the nineteen sixties the Americans
wanted in just the same way other
countries to fight in a Coalition of the
Willing as it might have been called in
Vietnam and when one English visitor in
Washington at the end of that decade was
talking to Dean Rusk would mean
Secretary of State Rusk said to him all
we wanted was one goddamn battalion of
the Black Watch and they didn't get them
although the Black Watch have been
fighting as you will know in Basra the
final legacy of mr. Blair's prime
ministership and of his foreign policy
has been to demonstrate the hollowness
of this relationship there is again I
hope I can be acquitted of
anti-americanism whatever it means in
this context when I say that any
American administration thinks of
American interests first but this has
been shown quite dramatic degree by the
Bush administration it has been said
that the Bush administration's watchword
when dealing with its enemies is odorant
unmet giant and let them hate just so
long as they fear us but it's it's its
precept when dealing with its supposed
friends sometimes seems to be taken from
Prince Watson Berg in 18-49 when he said
they will be astonished by our
ingratitude
when mr. Blair reacted as I have said in
my view absolutely rightly after 9/11 by
surprise expressing total support for
the United States his immediate reward
was a tariff likely to destroy what is
left to the British steel industry the
Bush administration does not appear to
believe in gratitude and in that respect
and we come which is where I'll leave it
for the moment to the single most
fascinating an ominous moment of mr.
Blair's Prime Minister in terms of
foreign politics which was April 2004
when he came to Washington and when
British troops were fighting in Iraq and
when the war had already become
grievously unpopular in England and when
mr. Blair's Austin's or reasons for the
war in the first place have been shown
to be untrue and if you remember he was
preceded to Washington by mr. Sharon the
Israeli prime minister and Sharon and
Borgia cut a deal
again I expressed no views on this of my
own as to whether it was right or wrong
but cutting deals is what politicians do
both of them had something they wanted
Bush by by demonstrating his support for
Israel wanted to carry Florida in the
coming presidential election without
resorting to quite the Barak means of
the previous election and mr. Sharon
wanted something else he had decided
finally he who not long before had said
that Israel would forever remain in Gaza
for Zionist reasons had finally realized
like most Israelis and got there quicker
than him that the game wasn't worth the
candle and that Israel was get out of
Gaza and it was absurd to devote half
their military resources to Gaza but he
had to sweeten the pill for his more
intransigent followers and what he
wanted and what he got from President
Bush was a public statement that with
any eventual settlement and presumably a
Palestinian state there will be no
return to the 1967 borders and there
would be no right of return as it's
called for the Palestinian refugees from
before them now as I say yet again the
rights and wrongs of this and neither
here nor there this was a total
repudiation of existing British policy
which were held not that which didn't
take a particular side on either of
those questions the border or the right
of return but insisted that there has
been no anticipation of such issues
until there was indeed a final
settlement it was also I think a
repudiation of existing American policy
but that's another matter
and Blair turned up in Washington to be
presented by this with this as a fait
accompli and all he could do was say he
saw hope for the future in it but it was
as even I may say his most
voted supporters in London admitted at
that time a total national and personal
humiliation and it was then that great
posse of former ambassadors wrote an
unprecedented letter criticizing mr.
Blair of British ambassador's and which
was then as it were seconded by Sir
Roderick Raceway to former ambassador
Moscow last summer when he read an
article the like of which I'd never seen
by a former ambassador saying that Blair
had simply failed to represent the
interests of his own country and the it
is very hard I think for an objective
observer of this story to sit to say
that Braithwaite was wrong
Blair there's policy which may possibly
in some ways have been sincere by his
own lights to begin with has ended up by
presenting the country which is prime
minister to the world as a kind of
satellite or puppet state and in my view
that is not good for his country of
which I am a citizen or for yours for
those of you who are American and I
think that the special relationship as
it has been called has now run its
course and that under the next prime
minister or the one after that presumed
to Gordon Brown and possibly then David
Cameron there will be a considerable
realignment of British policy won't be
done in an aggressive way I've I hide
the man after all Gordon Brown was here
there near the other day and met
President Bush of the first time and
David Cameron makes the right noises
about friendship with America but
Cameron began last autumn and a very
interesting important speech to detach
himself from an uncritical support for
American policy and I think you can be
fairly sure that is what is going to
happen over the next few years thank you
I'm now going to invite Christopher
Hitchens and after him Tim Montgomery to
respond then I'm after they each both
have spoken I will turn back to Geoffrey
and ask him perhaps to discuss some
aspects also the
of the domestic changes that may occur
as a result of the change of a prime
minister and then I'll throw it open to
the floor and Christopher sir
ladies gentlemen comrades brothers and
sisters c-span viewers wish I'd brought
my own book to way if I didn't think of
it not a John rather sadly strangely
neglected book on the special
relationship called a blood class and
Empire now available in paperback and at
fine bookstores everywhere which argues
against the view very more more much
more recently and with much more
publicity and panache taken by Andrew
Roberts who has a rather proprietorial
attitude towards anglo-american
relations and thinks that they belong in
some mystical way to the anglo-saxon
right-wing in some deeply layered manner
it's a common almost ethnic and literary
inheritance of a conservative kind
argues my book argues that actually the
the two great paradoxes about the
special relationship one is that it's
historically been something that's
flourished mainly on the left of center
I could take a long time justifying this
but I'll I'll condense as much as I can
but it'll I think throw some of
Geoffrey's remarks into some relief one
of the oldest traditions of the English
radical left is an affection for the
United States for the American
Revolution for America as the land of
equality not just of opportunity but of
the franchise of the opening of land to
the landless of the refugee of the
persecuted and the immigrants the the
reactionaries of the 19th century spent
an enormous time charles dickens
american notes would be the the salient
case here trying to discredit the
american revolution and it's British
sympathizers the locust classic us of my
case would be something they don't teach
you in school I suppose the the great
campaign by Karl Marx and Friedrich
Engels to defend the American Union
against secession and slavery in the
eighteen sixties at a time when everyone
from the liberal hypocrite William
Gladstone to the London Times to the
government of the day to the cotton and
other interests favored the Confederacy
and hope to build it a navy in the city
of Liverpool if you read the education
of Henry Adams think you'll have to
agree still the classic American memoir
and autobiography you will find that
when he was attached to his father's
unhappy ministry in London at that
period he found that his only friends
were the Friends of Karl Marx and the
only friends of the American Union were
the English working men's associations
this is a tradition that hasn't been
completely buried yet and I think stands
in need of some resuscitation so I'd
stipulate that to begin with but there's
another paradoxes you might say goes the
other way the reason why you need a
special relationship to start off with
is the need of the British Empire to dis
burden itself of colonies that it could
no longer afford to pay for or governed
or defend the entire rise to power as an
empire the United States not the entire
because well that would mean exempting
the war against the Spanish Empire but
the the greater part of the American
rise to an unchallenged world dominance
is the direct succession that is
involved between British governments
confessedly saying to Washington that
they can no longer stand the strain and
that because of other engagements in
Europe usually with Germany they require
American help and the price for this
will be the transfer of some colonies
perhaps a gold standard or two here and
there and some other responsibilities if
you look at where American troops are
currently deployed in the world and
where they've been deployed for a great
deal of time or where they're engaged in
the difficulties that some of which
Geoffrey mentions you will find whether
it's Palestine Israel whether it's the
Durand Line in Afghanistan Pakistan
whether it's the borders of Iraq or in
innumerable other places I could cite
and you could add these are lines drawn
by retreating having the long
withdrawing roar if you like of British
colonialism for the Americans to have
picked up this responsibility so what
should we say
perhaps incautiously and some respects
uncomplainingly is to give you an idea
of how the inequality sometimes goes if
you like the other way Churchill and
Roosevelt as you will know they're
they're often thought it was the
heavenly twins in the special
relationship nobody who's read William
Roger Lewis's edition of their complete
correspondence can fail to notice mr.
Churchill hated mr. Roosevelt mr.
Roosevelt despised had nothing but
contempt for mr. Churchill and it was a
race ready to see which of these two
emotions would get the upper hand mr.
Churchill did not like the price that
was exacted from him for lend-lease did
not like being told that the
Congressional isolationists had to be
appeased and the British colonies had to
be given up for every tranche of aid in
the in the miserly way that it was
handed out at the time as Geoffrey said
when London itself was being bombed and
when the American ambassador mr. Joseph
Kennedy of ill-repute until Fame and and
on the mourned memory was an open
sympathizer of the Third Reich faced
very hard to picture a less happy moment
than that the the relationship between
President act by private President
Truman and Prime Minister Attlee at the
dawn of the Cold War a great deal warmer
and more natural between Democrats and
Labor Ernest Bevin in fact signed the
NATO treaty with a signet ring that had
been given to him this was mr. Ali's
foreign secretary a signet ring given to
him as a young man by Samuel Gompers
found with the mo Confederation of
labour that's the British snap still on
the NATO treaty the the post labor
relationship between surrounding Eton
and the United States is probably well
known and well remembered as the lowest
moment there ever was the eviction of
Britain France and Israel from Suez by
President Eisenhower his willingness not
just to tell the Israelis they couldn't
sell Israeli bonds in New York anymore
if they weren't out of Gaza by the end
of the week but he's openly saying to a
British prime minister that he would
withdraw
dollar support for the Sterling pound
and willingness to actually do so is the
origin of something that is very little
understood on this side of the Atlantic
the extreme
the United States felt by large sections
of the British Conservative Party from
then on muted for reasons of tact and
reasons of diplomacy but very strong and
palpable mr. macmillan the successor of
that of her practically installed in
Downing Street buyers and house pressure
had actually a relationship of family
with President Kennedy as well as a sort
of avuncular relationship that went
beyond that but it was a fairly tepid
business and fairly short-lived and it
founded on the refusal of United States
to take seriously Britain's claim to be
an independent rather than a subordinate
to American nuclear power cantering I'll
keep this counter as short as I can but
I think it's necessary to set the scene
the the Wilson Callaghan labor
governments of the 70s 60s were
immolated interface I would say
immolated morally and politically by
their decision that at all costs they
had to support the American position in
Indochina in return for American support
for the Sterling area and the price of a
highly overvalued part when the pound
collapsed and when the Vietnam
enterprise collapsed also you I think a
generation of latent or blatant anti
Americans had been created all across
the British media all across the British
a khadeem all across actually the
generation born as I was in the early
years of the baby boom a catastrophe
from which neither country is yet
recovered Prime Minister Heath didn't
like the Americans particularly didn't
like secretary snake hissing or
President Nixon believed Britain's jest
nearly entirely with Europe mrs.
Thatcher was exactly the other way
around as you know use the United States
to enhance British prestige
internationally and as leverage against
Europe thus skipping only the
contemptible figure of John Major who
managed to be despised all across the
United States and all across Europe in
part because he helped to fail Europe's
first post 1989 test the first serious
test Europe had to undergo after its
reunification after the end of the Cold
War you know was it's part of failure to
prevent the recrudescence of air
fascism in former Yugoslavia Majors case
not even not to prevent it but to be
seconding it's supporting it endorsing
it helping it stepping over that put the
palling episode when we come to tony
blair we have to we have to acknowledge
whatever else we may have to say
something very important and unique and
unprecedented they had not before been a
prime minister of United Kingdom who was
neither pro-european nor in the Contra
sense pro-american didn't feel he had to
choose between the two felt at home with
both relationships was as as easy if you
like taking a holiday in Tuscany as he
would have been playing American songs
in that rock band of his or with
American culture in general and of the
right generation to be doing all these
things no more playing off Washington
against what Brussels Washington against
Paris Washington against but none of
that but able to know a crisis when he
saw one and of also another achievement
to have been a good personal friend in
time of trouble of two very radically
different presidents mr. Clinton and
later mr. Bush and when I say standing
by them in time of trouble I make no
particular point about whether Prime
Minister Blair should have been so
fawning on on President Clinton when he
was caught lying and perjuring and
fornicating in the Oval Office and the
Lincoln Bedroom I make I'd rather move
directly to September the 11th and the
serial consequences all wait and say
what I mean by in time of trouble and
quote John Howard their prime minister
of the of Australia who went accused of
being too uncritically probe or
enthusiastically pro-american in the
same epoch and being apparently willing
to go wherever America might lead said
in his own mistakable turns well there's
not much point in being 60% of a friend
at a time like this and I thought a very
good and useful remark simple but not
completely uncomplicated because 60%
friendship is not what anybody needs in
a in a time when civil society has been
attacked by the most
violent and promiscuous form of
barbarism to have emerged in this
generations lifetime so I'm not a bit
surprised and surprised or shocked mere
sorry to say Jeffrey in the least that
mr. Blair can be overheard speaking
soothingly to mr. Bush in st. Petersburg
that's sort of part of the prime
ministerial job and it's well known that
mr. Bush's are slightly prickly an
impatient person it's much more
interesting what mr. Blair said in
public and he's been criticized much
more for what he said deliberately on
the podium of his party conference which
were the following words shortly after
September 11th he said addressing our
American friends cousins comrades he
said we were with you with the first and
we will be with you till the last that
surely is what friendship and solidarity
actually mean so Christopher Mayer in
the Jeffrey uses the euphemism gossipy
for the tawdry little book that our
former envoi here produced on this
summit said that when he heard the words
he began to feel uneasy because he said
words like that have consequences you
might be taken up on them well I I ask
you ladies and gentlemen what is the
point of making a declaration of
unconditional brotherhood and solidarity
if you're not prepared to be taken up
when it was the value of your word what
in fact are your values if such is not
the case the the main sub r EK or
epithet that mr. blair has reaped for
this unequivocal position for the
friendship is the word poodle there
isn't a child in england who doesn't
know how to repeat this childish
accusation mr. Blair is mr. Bush's
poodle they hear it from Charlie adults
they pick it up and they they are they
giggle over it themselves well let me
just remind you of something it was not
mr. Clinton all Secretary of State
Albright who wanted to finish the job
with slobodan milosevic
and his mad dream of a greater Serbia
and an ethnically cleansed and
pulverized Balkans a wave of fascism
would have spread into Hungary and
Romania and Transylvania and beyond if
it hadn't been
and perhaps into Greece and Turkish
relations if it hadn't been contained
it was Prime Minister Blair who urged
them to do it and said the British
troops will be willing to do it even if
American troops were not this is not
poodle them this is not around our land
Alya this is not poodle them Mr Blair
demonstrated the same fortitude in the
case of Sierra Leone and went over the
objections of almost everybody who
thought well why not
just leave a treaty torn up with an
African country former dependency of
ours founded to protect runaway and
freed slaves why not them let them be
overrun by a Liberian invasion run by a
group of hand lopping thugs and
irredentist with very strong ties
through the Germans and blood John and
racket to al-qaeda who cares if we don't
stand by the treaty anywhere it's not
worth the life of a British grenadiers
Mr Blair took review that was not the
case and that the cost of no casualties
at all turned the invasion back greatly
I think to his credit in the case of
Afghanistan as we know he also said to
the President Bush the British troops
who were ready to intervene directly not
just by proxy through the Northern
Alliance whether American forces were
available or not but more important
still I think in showing the purity of
this poodle charge is the speech he gave
in 1999 in Chicago at she was part of a
series of speeches after the removal of
slobodan milosevic from power Mr Blair
repeatedly said at a time when George
Bush was a governor of Texas preparing
to run as an isolationist against the
interventionism of Albert Gore and Bill
Clinton against the interventionism that
Bush denounced and Cheney denounced in
the debate so you're using American
troops for nation-building you can't do
that you're using them for humanitarian
purposes around the world that's not
what our 82nd airborne is for you're
quite wrong President Clinton and Vice
President Gore had repeatedly sworn that
there would be another appointment with
Saddam Hussein that would have to be
kept one time or another but but before
that mr. Blair had said we have one
dictator down we have another to go
there's a nun post burnable
confrontation with Saddam Hussein and
the only question is going to be does he
pick the timing of it or do we and just
for once just for once we pick the
timing
up until then Saddam chose I know when
I'll invade Iran I know well invade when
I'll invade Kuwait I know when I'll send
jet squads to hijack tourists the boats
in the Mediterranean I know when I'll
give sanctuary to the man who blew up
the World Trade Center in 1993 I have
the initiative here I can switch
allegiance from the pro2 Islamic Jihad
and Hamas and pay for the suicide
bombings in Palestine to keep the West
off birds I call the shots here
he decided win that beer crisis now for
deciding that for once we would pick the
moment we have never heard the end and
we never will hear the end from our
favorite journalists and clever clogs
types never hear the end of a campaign
of slander and cynicism and defamation
because we produce the necessary
evidence because we said this man is a
permanent menace with his genocidal
politics his weapons of mass destruction
his unending support for nihilism and
terrorism it's not just we've waited
we're doing this too quickly it's we've
waited far too long and for this as I
say that the campaign of hateful
misrepresentation has never and I think
never will stop proof positive by the
way the history is not always written by
the winners the losers have written this
and I expect they will carry the day in
the history books
that's all end with two ironies actually
Mr Blair probably spoiled everything
for the relationship and for himself by
being untrue to the principles I've just
described
he asked for after the United Nations
Security Council had voted unanimously
unanimously including the vote of Syria
to require on pain of serious
consequences that Iraq after decades of
defiance come into compliance with the
relevant resolutions not just on
weaponry but on many other things to a
resolution that good legal minds have
said and any moral sense would tell you
was self-enforcing and long overdue and
representing finally the unanimity that
any organization of international
stature with any vertebra should have
had to feel it her to pass Syria not
exempt you mr. Blair said let's just try
this again let's have another resolution
because I need it from my parliamentary
Labour Party a rather parochial Djem and
mounting if you like to something of a
quid pro quo a political favor of a
poetry kind and because he's not a
poodle and isn't regarded as such by the
administration that's another
misrepresentation and libel because they
take him so seriously because British
advice is heated because British
prestige does amount to something
because the Prime Minister is understood
as a serious person he was given what he
asked and therefore the whole noble
Enterprise of the removal of Saddam
Hussein became a matter of nuts and
bolts and details and matters of timing
exact locations of sources and methods
of terror and wng trivializing the whole
matter into one of inspections and
reducing it to the very banal stage in
which the argument is declined today
thus Mr Blair undid his cause and
himself and his place in history I think
not by being too much in line with the
policy of the United States correct as
it was but by being not so much so
insufficiently so closing irony remember
what I said about the way the Tories
have always hated and resented the loss
of their empire and the assumption of
those responsibilities that they
couldn't discharge any longer and
overlook the empty letters sent by the
Arabist dinosaurs of the Foreign and
Commonwealth Office who have never got
anything right and never will and note
that Jeffrey said that it was last
autumn that the little charmer an
impostor and published publicity
specialist David Cameron made a measured
statement taking his distance from the
United States wasn't last autumn ladies
and gentlemen he was on the morning of
September the 11th that he called his
press conference and told the American
Embassy that he would not be available
for any other events he was going to
make his own little declaration of
independence as a conservative and to
say that from now on on this day of all
days the United States could not count
on any further British friendship
could not count on it as an axiom or
could not count on it as a principle it
would from now on have to be bargained
for who would have to be traded it would
have to be quid pro quo well that works
for me
and it works for my thesis it works for
my book because it replaces the virus of
anti-americanism where it always was
where it ought to be and where it
belongs on the forces of reaction and
with the rump of the British Tory party
whose strange death as adumbrated by
Geoffrey cannot come quick enough for me
thank you well Tim as a leading member
of the Conservative Party
those must be fighting words estranged
me to come to Washington because I end
up seeming always defending tony blair
in some way just how am i going to start
these remarks tony blair if anyone has
devastated my party the conservative
party and laterally over the last 10
years or so it has been him he has
confounded us at every turn confusing us
and defeating us three times to a huge
extent so I have no love for the man no
that's where I start my position there
my response to what's been said so far
but erm I can only agree with that with
what Christopher Hitchens said about
this whole poodle myth it is absolutely
ridiculous and there's no evidence for
it if you look at the chronology is
absolutely true and Christopher said
what I really wanted to say about this
was that if you want a defining text
ready for a lot of what george w bush
has done since 9/11 and through what has
gone on in afghanistan and iraq you do
have to look back to that chicago speech
and what tony blair and did was in many
ways led and the view that the Bush
White House has pursued so it's a very
strange
of poodle that actually wrote the script
for a lot of things that have happened
since those since there's times I think
the great thing that was missing from
Oliver definitely costs remarks was
really the the scale of the threat that
Western civilization faces at the moment
from Islamic fascism I think there are
very few people in England who
understand threat that we all face Tony
Blair is one of them he understood it
right away after 9/11 and I think that
is what unites him and President Bush it
isn't some sort of slavish sense that he
has to be loyal to president loyal to
America I think he appreciates the great
dangers that civilization and faces now
I happen to believe that as Tony Blair
has incompetently managed most of the UK
affairs since it became prime minister
in 1997 I think the way the Iraq war has
been progressed has been incompetent and
a lot of advice that should have been
listened to by defense and foreign
policy experts wasn't heeded not least
warnings two three years ago by senators
McCain and Lieberman about the need for
many more troops and I make no defence
of Tony Blair's competence but I do
think the idea his approval
the idea that somehow he didn't come to
the views that he had independently and
first is simply very very bad history
and I want to focus I think the subject
of the discussion is the future of the
relationship between our two countries
United States and United Kingdom and
then I think my job John is to focus
particularly on the conservative parties
and place in that future and that's what
I intend to do for the rest of my
remarks there has been a huge
deterioration in the Conservative
Party's view of the United States
in recent times and them I personally
regret that I think a lot of it is to do
with I think a fairly great failures in
the White House great failures within
team Bush to realize that there are
disagreements between friends and when
those disagreements occur and you work
at overcoming them because there are
long-term benefits and especially in the
special relationship between our two
countries and special relationships
between parties like the Republicans and
the Conservatives that need to stand the
test of time
and need to be to be worked out but
Michael Howard the former Conservative
Party leader made some very unfortunate
remarks about the Iraq war when in an
interview for The Sunday Times he said
that if he knew then what he knew now
about a little period before the last
general election and he would not have
voted for the Iraq war it was a foolish
thing for Michael Howard to say and the
White House took great exception to this
there was a lot of telephone traffic
between the Conservative Party and the
White House and the White House made it
very very clear that the Conservative
Party leader would no longer be welcome
at the the White House and that has been
a problem in the relationship ever since
there has been there's been no
commitment to keep two parties close the
parties of Thatcher and Reagan etc that
really should be should be closed and
standing together on so many important
issues back at Michael house right hand
at the time he had that White House snub
was David Cameron David Cameron was very
much Michael Howard's process J and
David Cameron remembers that that it's
like remembers the great coldness that
began between the Conservative Party and
the Bush administration and the
Conservative Party at that time and this
is something I would very much agree
with what Jeffrey a week Ross said I
think the Bush administration has been
very bad at maintaining alliances
and the steel tariffs example he cited
was an example where there's been no
real effort to keep important friends
onside and I think that's a too big to
be greatly regretted as we look forward
and I don't think that the Conservative
Party Republican Conservative Party
America relationship and so far as a
relationship with George W Bush is going
to be fixed and I don't think there is
any willingness and the team Cameron to
want it to be to be fixed there David
Cameron if he becomes Prime Minister
won't become Prime Minister until George
W Bush has left the White House he is
not part of the Conservative Party's
calculations and there are stories that
have recently surfaced in the in the
press in Britain of conscious attempts
by the Conservative Party leadership to
manufacture rouse with the Bush White
House the Bush White House is incredibly
unpopular in in Great Britain at the
moment and the Conservative Party sees
tactical advantage in being seen to be
at odds with them this is how far the
situation has deteriorated I report this
with no pride I report it with great
disappointment but I report it isn't the
situation that is now exists between the
Bush administration and the Conservative
Party this is that not to say that the
Conservative Party however does not want
a relationship with America and a
positive relationship very recently as
has been mentioned we had John Senator
John McCain and come and speak to the
annual Conservative Party conference and
we've just been announced that it later
on this year the Governor of California
will be addressing and the Conservative
Party conference they consider party
does want to keep a relationship with
the Republicans it wants to keep a
relationship open with America but I
think it is important for Americans to
understand that it is a different
Conservative Party and than it has been
in the past it is not
the party of Margaret Thatcher in so
many ways the Conservative Party is
becoming much more European much more
European in its views for example on Tax
Cameron team Cameron have largely
accepted and the European levels of
Taxation the Gordon Brown has has levied
of us and it was notable that whereas
nearly all of the Anglosphere nations
including tony blair john howard stephen
harper george w bush sided with israel
during the last summer's conflict in
Lebanon and David Cameron was openly
critical of Israel like most of the
leaders of the EU and the United Nations
whereas the war on terror and crucially
climate change the Conservative Party
much more now resembles something that
is Christian Democratic rather than
Republican and I think it's notable that
probably the policy change that David
Cameron is most known for since became
leader of the consider party has been
his support for Kyoto and I don't think
it is any accident that John McCain and
the Governor of California or other two
people two Republicans he's deemed
acceptable to come to Britain and to be
that he wants to be associated with him
in conclusion I would say that if the
Conservative Party is no longer the
party of Margaret Margaret Thatcher is a
different party that America and the
Republican Party now has to deal with I
would also say that the Labour Party
soon will not be the party of Tony Blair
Tony Blair I think has been I think that
the the American the Bush administration
has put far too many eggs in the Tony
Blair basket they have very few other
good political friends and relationships
and in the UK anybody who wasn't
entirely supportive of Blair has been
ostracized by them and when Blair goes
they will find a Labour Party that is
much much more hostile to America it is
a guaranteed cheer line on the fringe
meeting of the Labour Party conference
last year that if you attack neo
conservatism which is probably
the biggest swear word you could use in
in Britain at the moment that you would
you would raise the chair so I think it
is although I have many disappointments
about how the concerted party has
behaved in recent times I think that
America will find in the medium term
that a party which still has people like
George Osborne William Hague and Duncan
Smith Liam Fox
these are Atlantis there are many fewer
atlantis cysts in the labour party and
in the long run
the conservative party different as it
is now compared to 10 20 years ago will
be a durable and reliable partner for
america in the next stages of what I
learned today we no longer able to call
the war on terror the Labour government
has announced today that it's going to
learn they will no longer be using that
expression as a government and but
undoubtedly that is what we're still
involved in an age of terror but I think
it will be the Conservative Party that
in the long term America find a more
reliable partner in thank you Tim thank
you very much indeed as I said I would
like to just turn to Jeffrey for a
moment and ask him has he got any
particular comment to make on the likely
domestic consequences and particularly
if the Labour Party Timms last point of
the lack of the change of prime
ministership that this will take place I
suppose in about three months it's not
sooner I didn't there will be a drastic
change the the domestic politics of
Great Britain from which Christopher's
no little remote
complex at the moment quite comical and
in the the whole of Tony Blair's cabinet
are contriving to get the impression
that to the last man or woman they're
all taking part in an Antarctic
expedition when the invasion of the rock
took place it had absolutely nothing to
do with them one or another they have
tried to use various ruses and sites of
hand to dissociate themselves from it
though they can't of course quite do so
Road a Gordon Brown is a strong Atlanta
system and in the tradition that
Christopher mentioned I mean that
there was never a stronger Atlanta Syst
defense secretary in London than Dennis
Healey who was as fierce an
anti-communist as a million
ex-communists can be and there has
indeed been a tradition of labor support
for the Atlantic Alliance I just want to
take up a couple of points if I may of
Christopher's very quickly you mentioned
the Civil War and the fact the undoubted
fact that English radicals in the 19th
century had marred American that English
reaction was as you call them tended to
ask I mean there was more and more
perhaps a snobbery and which persisted
indeed in Europe in the 20th century of
reactionary and quasi aristocratic
contempt for America but don't forget
the other way around during the Civil
War the Secretary of State wanted to
declare war in Great Britain and was
only restrained by President Lincoln
himself saying I think one more at a
time was to Seward and that after the
war and Christopher mentioned the
warships built in Europe from one in
particular the Alabama led to a huge
crisis between the two countries and
several senators in Washington thought
that the only possible adequate
restitution for this the building of the
Alabama in Birkenhead
would be the session of Canada to the
United States and Robert Kagan points
out in his recent book dangerous nation
about America as an international power
in the 19th century the first two
volumes the second will come up to date
but every leading American or very many
leading Americans from the beginning
believe that the manifest destiny of the
United States was to absorb the whole of
the North American continent notably
Canada the point about I'm sorry I'm not
in this these are simply individual
points the I'd see one they were Tim's
Tim is of course the on the pro-american
wing of the Tory Party and there is
certainly an anti-american tradition in
tourism it is rather died out in the
nineteenth between the wars if you could
still find it in the old Morning Post
which was the high Tory newspaper until
it sold in the searches
recently with people like Enoch Powell
Donald Clark on the somewhat easier sinc
ratting right of the party but it is
interesting to me that every other
European country has a right-wing party
or a conservative party whose
fundamental definition is its dedication
to the national interest of that country
and the didn't my country we have a
Conservative Party at least one element
which seems to be dedicated to the
national interest of another country I
mean the United States they do not
necessarily have the same interest
otherwise they were sometimes they do
sometimes they don't the the point about
Clinton Lucas was um reflections on the
president's character is is that a
friend of mine who knows Blair quite
well does say this is too long a topic
to deal with fully but he says that the
the most damning thing he regards the
wall about as conduct was the adjoint
miss was which he switched from Clinton
to Bush but your point about the Clinton
administration's hostility to Iraq which
is a point you continually make was
answered by Clinton himself actually
when he was in London not long ago he
said that indeed it was the policy of an
administration to have regime change in
Baghdad and also in Havana but he had
not for that reason invaded Cuba and I
don't always quote Clinton with approval
but I think that as a legitimate point
um you also mentioned mrs. Thatcher and
it is true that she was she formed a
very close personal bond with President
Reagan and they had a genuine common
interest in pursuing the Cold War to its
end which they achieved was triumphant
success as I have already said mrs.
Thatcher was much more detached in some
ways from the United States then people
realized or than Tony Blair has been and
I will give you we were talking about
last summer 19 2006 came back 20 years
to 1986 mrs. Thatcher visited Washington
which she mentions this briefly in her
book which one is familiar and she but
we know we have a more authentic version
from the NSC archives
she met George Shultz the Secretary of
State at the time and gave him the kind
of tongue lashing that Parliament and
her cabinet and the British people were
very familiar with she said there would
be no peace in the Middle East until
justice was done for the Palestinians
she wanted to know if the Israeli
government government regarded the
historic land of Israel as its natural
territory and she said that the greatest
obstacle to progress was the
unconditional support given by the
United States to the Israeli government
in whatever actions it took this is
Margaret Thatcher and when that year
also the Israelis bombed the PLO at
headquarters in Tripoli in contrast to
Blair last summer who said who stood by
the Americans in the Israelis when the
Israeli bombarded southern Lebanon mrs.
Thatcher said she would not endorse this
Israeli action she said we cannot have
countries attacking other countries
however vexatious and unpleasant they
are against the normal rules of
international conduct and she said what
would the American response be if I
bombed the IRA and dumb dog and that's a
very good question
perhaps I can I can come in on this
point precisely ripped a book about the
Thatcher Reagan relationship among other
people recently now it seems to me that
so thank you very much but it seems to
me that the the the the fact of that
relationship was this that there were
they Reagan and Thatcher representing it
seems to me here the national interests
of both countries very well saw that
they had a common political task to
perform
essentially in winning the Cold War they
had differences of opinion sometimes
very serious ones in in the course of
that joint campaign the most the one
that became public was of course Grenada
and Grenada became public partly because
mrs. Thatcher who I think was
essentially mistaken on this point but
not on Grenada as a whole but part
because mrs. Thatcher was left out of
the loop and publicly humiliated in
effect by the Reagan administration at
the beginning of that crisis but in
general and they muffled the
disagreements in pub
gave each other strong political support
in public
having thrashed out their differences in
private and that seems to me to point
make to lead on to two other points one
of them is that why is it that Britain
has generally as as Geoffrey where I
think rightly said has a political has
has a both of state policy and political
parties which tend to find themselves
more often in alliance with the United
States and with some other
english-speaking countries whereas the
nationalist or conservative parties in
Europe tend to be much more attentive to
the nano short term interest and I think
the answer is a very simple one that in
the case of Britain the United States
Canada New Zealand Australia but these
are all countries shaped fundamentally
by the same political values now there
are differences in those values
I concede but nonetheless when you take
when you look at the countries shaped by
the English language the common-law
tradition of ordered Liberty and so on
they will tend to have a return alliance
not based on sentiment that I agree is
amiss it would be mistaken but on a
similarity of outlook in world affairs
which leads them therefore to find
themselves generally cooperating with
each other and that leads me to
Christopher's point I must say I was
tremendously charmed by his argument
that the special relationship his
business was safer in the hands of Karl
Marx than it was in the hands of Hanuman
millon mrs. Thatcher and so on
he he drew a particular attention to the
he drew a particular attention to the
sewers episode and that was and Jeffrey
did too that was I think the single most
important case of of anglo-american
breeder Beach of relations in which they
took very opposite sides both Jeffrey
and Christopher come together here in
taking sides with Eisenhower I'm
actually on even side as indeed dollars
and Eisenhower subsequently them that
became became themselves and you may
remember that if Eisenhower felt that
invading an Arab country would lead to a
generations of hatred throughout the
entire world one wonders why he invaded
Lebanon the following year
which she did and install the government
so now the the point the find of the
point however of I was making here is
that look at the biographies of the Suez
group the most intransigent
conservatives on the right over sewers
John Biggs Davidson Juliana Marie these
people were in fact the strongest
supporters of America in the seventy in
the 60s the 70s and the 80s despite the
fact that they believed that the United
States had been mistaken and misguided
in its Suez policy why for the reason I
gave before that they they believed that
they were shaped by the a similar
outlook on world affairs which led them
to see the necessity of American actions
on a global scale and not to pursue a
parochial a narrow parochial interest at
the time which I think they would have
been doing had they based their policies
or their politics on a policy of
resentment about sewers for the next
twenty years
well I'll move on now to questions from
the floor and ask who would like to
raise the first one gentleman is Stephen
Morris perhaps people could say where
relevant where they're from and who they
are University size I'd like the panel
to consider the following in may we may
it be at a great historical moment in
that in France we may see the election
of the first Atlantis's president in in
over fifty years the first solidly
Atlantis's president and if that happens
you will see in also in Germany with
mrs. Merkel the compliment the two major
powers of continental Europe in the
hands of Pro Atlantic pro-american
governments now from the perspective of
whoever is in power in Britain assuming
that certain we know that French
presidencies is going to last seven
years I don't know about the Coalition
in in Germany but let's assume that
there we're going to have several more
years of this the two continental powers
being pro-american how is it going to
create or how is it going to constrain
the options of people like the
vessels in the Conservative Party you've
mentioned who who simply respond to
public opinion by creating an
international political European
political environment which is
pro-american and do you think also that
the advent of an Atlantis is hardcore in
continental Europe with these two is
going to affect public opinion not only
in Europe but also in Britain you're
addressing that to anyone in particular
okay thanks
Christopher first Jeffrey later well I
must say I think it's an admirable
question and I wish I'd thought of
phrasing it that way myself I mean
implicit somewhat in what both of my
contraire have been saying is the idea
that the friendship with the United
States can be considered mainly as a
liability these days I really don't
think that's true and if the British
care to drop what has up till then being
given to them naturally so to say he'll
come to the naturally they may suddenly
find that there are others who are very
interested in becoming America's best
friend and very eager for what would be
for any European country of any economic
development and political prestige quite
a prize to have to be America's best
friend I remember very particularly in
1990 going to Aspen Colorado for a
summit meeting between then President
Bush the first and mrs. Thatcher where
wills great great depression in the
British camp diplomatically and
politically and in mrs. Thatcher's own
entourage the John remembers it there's
one of those involved because it looked
more and more as if United States
preferred her call and the newly
powerful and reunited Democratic Germany
to the rather Faustian traditions of the
special relationship and the first
couple of days of the meeting went you
know in a very depressing way in just
that manner and then we got the news
that Saddam was saying Saddam Hussein
had gone mad and had decided to abolish
the existence of Kuwait overnight to
abolish the existence of a member state
of the United Nations and the Arab
League discovering in the process that
it could be a big mistake to invade an
Arab country
if I might say so also a mistake to
invade a Persian country also a mistake
to be a fascist megalomaniac and a
practitioner of genocide other things
that ought to lead to condemnation in
isolation that don't often get enough
emphasis well at once mrs. Thatcher knew
where she stood
Britain has bases in the Gulf in Oman
for example it has experienced with
Kuwait which had probably invented it
has friends contracts it has a Navy
worth the name and so on she could do
things immediately for the president
that Helmut Kohl could never think of
offering so the moment passed but I
never forgot it I mean I'm very amazed
at any British Conservative would there
yes you're quite right the opportunities
there for the taking and I hope I'm sure
Mr Sarkozy is going to win and I very
much hope that he takes what David
Cameron so despises Tim and then
Geoffrey if you want to respond yes I
agree is a very interesting question
that to have I'm sure to replace first
by Merkel and Chirac then by Sarkozy I
agree it's probably going to happen and
I think it's interesting that his he he
hides his primary prism on the campaign
trail very very carefully he knows it
sir it's a vote loser so I wouldn't
expect too much in terms of a and
assertive or an ambitious and support of
the American worldview but yes the
hostility will be will be absent that
are so characterized president sure acts
presidency and the one great worry I
have with President Sarkozy is his
opposition to Turkey
joining the the EU I think the
membership of of turkey of EU is an
important sign by the Western world the
developing world the developed world
Europe now if you want to describe it
that a country with a huge Muslim
population that
improves its human rights that
democratizes that behaves in a proper
constitutional fashion will be welcomed
by other other nations of a Western war
Christian tradition and I think that
will be an enormous tension that he will
put at the heart of the West
relationship with Islam if he proceeds
on that basis and I'm afraid a lot of
why he takes that position is I fear for
a lot of the anti-islamic sentiment that
is now very strong in Europe and if not
managed well and presents all sorts of
problems in the future
Thank You Jeffrey yes the sorry I was
all by what Tim was saying that I've
gotten rise against said before that the
this question of sorry your question I
pick up on I think of one I accept the
premise by the way first of all the
assumption there for the Nicolas Sarkozy
is devoted to Atlantis ISM that to
borrow from Dorothy Parker the only ISM
Nicolas Sarkozy believes in his
opportunism and that he has been making
one noise one day and another the other
day and noon a one day he condemns the
black and Arab rioters as well in the
english-speaking press it was called
force calm it was actually a chi which
is rabble and the next day he says that
we must understand them and be nice to
them do not at all exaggerate any turn I
would suggest in European politics in
this respect yes
Sarkozy and Merkel are conservatives and
they don't want to play on the visceral
anti-americanism of a certain part of
the European left but neither of them
supported or would have supported the
Iraq war there is scarcely any leader of
any important European country who did
so or would have done so apart from
Blair and Ben
and you want should be very careful of
thinking that there is I hope that there
will be in some respects warmer
relations between the European Union and
the United States but but they don't
count too much on that and there are two
things I think I can just knit together
yeah going back to something Christopher
said much earlier about the way that the
Iraq war began Blair's mistake in his
view of trying to get second United
Nations resolution and and Christopher
mentions almost disdainfully the
parliamentary Labour Party well I'm
sorry this is what's known as democracy
I mean Blair took his country into a war
against the wishes of most of his own
MPs if they had been honest most of his
own cabinet if they'd be long history
and most of the citizens of that country
and it is to use the borough your word
iron it is the supreme irony that
responsibly
to bring democracy to Mesopotamia and
the larger Middle East democracy was
very badly damaged where it already
existed in my country which gave the
world parliamentary government in this
country which gave the government the
world government of the people by the
people for the people are the fact that
the the Parliament could be manipulated
in some ways bamboozled and supporting a
war against its real wishes at the
contrast indeed to 1940 and 1939 when
the a reluctant government British
government was pushed into war by
parliamentary and public opinion it was
completely the other way around in the
case of Iraq and the only resemblance to
the second resolution is the
manipulation was a vote in the House of
Commons of course which the Conservative
Party in which the Conservative Party
supported the casements to their
subsequent regret in any other but
anyway let's think you had your Georgian
Parliament already it was a shock to his
own party there's a Rowland dignified
way of making war because you you
somebody whose position on the war was
similar to a Christian was Michael
Ignatieff who was one of those and known
as liberal Hawks and he wrote a piece in
The New York Times about a year after
the invasion of Iraq in which he said
that he had been dismayed and
discomposed by the failure to find
so-called
mass destruction because he believed the
claims made in the first place some of
us weren't discomposed or dismayed
because we never had belief claims made
he then went on to say something which I
think Christopher for decoden to put
words in your mouth he said in hindsight
to be honest the proper case for the war
was not for a pre-emptive war to disarm
a dangerous tyrant who possessed mass
destructive weapons but a preventive war
to depose a dangerous I take that point
I said that I took the 20 then went on
saying glumly unfortunately for my side
in the argument if the honest case of
prevention rather than pre-emptive would
be made the war would have been even
more unpopular than it was quite sir I
take that one no good back next question
let's rest for good to the next question
from the front thank you for taking a
firm hand on the Scottish parliamentary
elections I think our Scottish
parliamentary elections coming up if
they elect a Scottish Nationalist Party
what chance do you see that they will
vote to secede it if so what is the
impact of British politics in the
british-american relationship for anyone
on the panel I think we probably begin
with Tim and coming this way I think the
question ashes will do very well
next next month students they will not
get a majority all opinion polls suggest
that they will be the largest party but
they will fall short of the majority and
they are of course the Scottish National
Party and they believe in independence
but they have said that they want
actually a referendum on independence
for three more years after
the Scottish elections because actually
a lot of the opinion poll evidence
suggests that it actually is one of
their least popular policies and some
polls have recently put support for
independence at 50% but others as low as
30 percent and the view I think is of
most commentators bassists the vote s
for the SM vote for the SNP is largely a
protest against labour and the school
bills the iraq war is one of the major
reasons why the Scottish Labour Party's
fortunes have declined and so much but I
think it would be a misreading to
believe that they vote Yes and P was a
vote for independence I think when the
weight of the main unionist party's
labour conservative and Liberal
Democrats is put behind a no vote should
that independence vote happen in three
years when Scotland will stay a part of
the United Kingdom and Thank You Jeffrey
yes I'm surprised and pleased to hear
them requests were brought up again
we're about to have the most fascinating
week in British politics for a long time
Tuesday the 1st May as the 300th
anniversary of the act of union between
England and Scotland Wednesday the
second way is the 10th anniversary of
Tony Blair's prime ministership and
Thursday the 3rd May is the elections in
local elections in England in which
labor looked like doing very badly and
the Scottish elections in which the SNP
seemed certain to come the largest party
because they have proportional
representation there a lot of plurality
but not a majority unlike mr. Blair by
the way who at the last British general
election won 54% of parliamentary seats
with just over 35 percent of the popular
vote I'm sorry
and finally convincing me of the need
for some kind of electoral reform I
didn't get like there will be an
independent Scotland in the foreseeable
future but it has shown up the the SNP
is position over Scotland is entirely
coherent and intellectually honest they
want independence labour on the other
hand was a belated
reluctant and completely insincere
convert to devolution and it was nothing
more than a political maneuver on the
part of labour under Tony Blair as it
came about because what label were
trying to do was just
a circle politically by holding off the
electoral challenge from the Scot lands
within Scotland while at the same time
keeping as many as possible of Labour's
Scottish rotten boroughs in the
Westminster Parliament without which you
cannot good luck now now it may not have
been noticed but here that at the last
British general election May 2005 the
tour is one the largest number of votes
in England not the largest on the follow
intercedes but they were in the largest
number of votes and they will I think
without any question I would have a
large bet whatever happens in the next
general election the Tories will win the
largest number of seats in England and
then there is going to be a severe
constitutional crisis in my view or I
didn't know that as I say whether it
will mean there will be a new Scotland a
new independent Scot although Alex
Salmond the leader of the Scottish
National Party has said recently rather
interestingly that he doesn't want to he
wants England to be Scotland's best
friend and vice versa he doesn't want to
have a separate currency and he doesn't
even want to leave the monarchy and this
suggests to me the heading towards an
earthlike like 1867 and the creation of
the austro-hungarian Dual Monarchy that
will see if you want to come in
Christopher I just say I as to go said
about the greatness of Brazil but it's
always something in the future and
that's where it will remain the
independence of Scotland and of Quebec
are just exactly like that the people
involved don't have the nerve to do it
for one thing or the guts and they also
know that the consequences will be
greater than they are ready to record
with first sub secession there are lots
of people in Quebec would want to leave
in different directions if they had to
be governed by the heirs of Peyton and
Pooja and the same would be true of
Scotland and the other is they would
complicate hugely their relations with
the European Union which is the only
reason they have enough prosperity but
getting on with to begin with and this
is by no means a certainty it seems to
be that an independent Scotland can
count on staying within without having
to reapply and perhaps have to take
another look at itself in the mirror so
it's a false issue it just won't happen
thank you now this will have to be the
final question I'm afraid is that one
yes gentlemen the second row I'm
standing over with the Cato Institute
I like come to pursue this question of
friendship I can understand that loyalty
is a manifestation of friendship but
isn't honest criticism also an act of
friendship um just this morning I heard
the gentleman a free speech a block away
on the war in Iraq reporting on a trip
he made there
the retired four-star general now at
West Point and in his trip report here
that was distributed he said that I'm
quoting in summary the US Armed Forces
are in a position of strategic power
unquote I'm sorry sorry what was the
word strategic paral paral if somebody
tries to warn you against putting your
Armed Forces in a position of strategic
peril is it that an active friendship
also I'm going to ask the three our
three speakers to answer the question
come starting with Tim and coming this
way very quickly as possible if you
would I think I I don't agree with this
tough criticism of the Iraq war but I do
think honest criticism is important i I
think there are many cases where this
relationship is stronger because of
honest criticism I think there is a
mischaracterization of what Jeffrey we
cross says that somehow Blair's position
has been poodle like I don't think he
has answered the charge that actually
Blair's analysis of the need for a
liberal intervention is actually
preceded Bush coming to power and I
think and there is there are a number of
examples of actually Blair having
affected u.s. policy by being engaged
with them and being critical behind the
scenes Christopher I was asked in I
think early October 2001 if I'd like to
come to the memorial service for the I
think it was about 400 British citizens
who've been murdered at work in the
World Trade Center the few weeks before
and I said no I don't want to come to a
special service for Brits
and I wish you wouldn't have one and I
don't think this is an attack on America
and I think the president is wrong to
describe it as that and I think that
Tony Blair is quite right and say that
we stand with the immediate victim in
this case the United States because we
recognize it as an attack on
civilization so I don't think that's a
distinction without a difference to you
so not a matter of loyalty or friendship
it's a matter I'd prefer to have
solidarity and it means Jeffrey says
what's NATO during an Afghanistan well
the answer to that is its Charter says
if one member is attacked all respond
that's why now that seems to me what
solidarity means literally and
ultimately in this case thank you and
Jeffrey yes of course I think that that
true friends are candid friends and that
you are the best since I think that the
Iraq war was a mistake neither of the my
friends on my left agree with that one
deep drone but I'm for once I'm not in a
minority except on this platform because
the view that there are core was a
mistake is not shared by the great
majority of Americans and of British
people and I think that tended Americans
who continued to admire Tony Blair as
quite a lot do might bear in mind that
he was pretty well the only person on
earth who might have been able to stop
the Iraq war if you think that the Iraq
war has been a brilliant achievement
then you should certainly a salute mr.
Blair if not then not and as my closing
remark because this has been cited so
often by Christopher and Tim and others
let us say the 1999 Chicago speech which
Tony Blair gave them the central text of
liberal interventionism and it was a
very good speech indeed in many ways not
surprisingly and since it wasn't written
by Mr Blair the crucial point of that
speech it was written by Lawrence
Freedman which then he said this these
are the words we must examine the
conditions before we take military
action first are we sure of our case
second have we exhaust exhausted all
diplomatic options
third on the basis of a practical
assessment of the situation are the
military operations we can
it's a billion prudently undertake forth
are we prepared for the long term in the
past we have talked too much of exit
strategies and finally do we have
national interests involved that is very
well put and eight years later I would
say were all of those conditions met in
the case of Iraq or indeed was any
ladies and gentlemen I want to draw this
debate to a close I think if we're
honest and I suspect you will share this
feeling there have been times during the
debate when we would have been rather
depressed but the fact is it was a very
honest reflection of some of the debates
and discussions and trends that are
currently taking place within Britain
and in British politics and Americans
should know that this is the case
secondly I I personally and this may not
be universal felt at times that
resentments were playing too large a
part in our discussion of attitudes
across the Atlantic in both directions
principally the British towards the
American of course there were have been
times in the last 200 years
Jeffrey mentioned the war of 1812 when
the two countries were injuring each
other and and they are not going to be
forgotten nor by historians should they
be forgotten but nor should they
necessarily dictate future attitudes and
future policies and there is a
temptation always that this should be
the case I think it's been a temptation
that since the settling of the
Venezuelan crisis by determined British
appeasement by Lord Salisbury in 1895
has been resisted the the British have
gained a great deal from deciding not to
pursue their interests their national
interest to the against the United
States in that particular conflict and
for the next hundred years there has
been a close relationship between the
two countries that relationship has been
best it seems to me on real long preface
of both at the moment that is not how it
is seen in Britain it's fair to say and
I think Geoffrey is giving us an
accurate depiction of British opinion
here
but then I remember a very important
point made by Christopher in the course
of the debate he described the situation
very accurately we miss mrs. Hatcher and
Downing's people in Downing Street felt
that the Americans were in a sense
rejecting the special relationship in
favour of a new special relationship
with Germany after Reagan the left
office and I think partly to distinguish
the Bush administration from the Reagan
administration and it's in its
relationship with mrs. Thatcher but of
course Kuwait came along and all of a
sudden it was more convenient and a
better expression of American interests
to return to the special relationship
now at that time mrs. Thatcher did not
follow a policy dictated by resentment
at the the fourth of treatment she had
been receiving for the previous year she
saw an opportunity to advance British
interests and also to repair an alliance
which had never really been shaken or
shattered but merely damaged at their
margins and as a result of that a very
successful policy was carried out I
think that overall we have to say that
the relationship that was in the sense
begun in 1895 solidified in 1941 and
triumphed triumphant in 1989 1991 is one
which you can never count out and at the
moment although at the moment it is
unfashionable British politics the
long-term national trends in both
countries will I think make it live
again I realize I'm giving their
tutorial opinion here and not expressing
my thanks to the board but I know I ask
you all to thank them for a lively and
vigorous debate
thank you very much